Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain an American docudrama film
called “Front of the Class.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Twelve-year-old Brad Cohen has Tourette syndrome.
Because of the condition, he makes strange noises,
twitches, and yells randomly. All these actions
are involuntary and Brad has no control over them.
But in the small town in Missouri, most people
are unfamiliar with Brad’s unique syndrome. They
do not believe him when he claims he cannot stop
the tics. Even his father Norman thinks his son
is making the noise to trouble his parents.
Brad’s classmates bully him often and the teachers
are of no help. The tics started when he was six
years old, around the time Brad’s parents were
getting divorced. Ever since, his mother has
taken him to several doctors, all of whom have
associated his tics with depression. That is why
the real cause has never been diagnosed and people
continue to believe he is just a spoiled brat.
Brad’s only friend is his younger brother, Jeff.
Although they fight and bicker all the time,
Brad feels like Jeff is the only person who gets
him. Their father Norman lives in another city and
visits them once in a while. He connects with Jeff
but Brad has always been sort of an embarrassment
for him. He often scolds the kid to stop yelling
and moving so much. His father's distrust
in him makes Brad feel like a failure.
Meanwhile, Brad’s mother Ellen has always been
supportive of her son. She believes him when
he says the tics are not something he can
control. Ellen is troubled by her friends
and relatives suggesting different absurd methods
to discipline her kid. Although she trusts Brad,
being a single mother with two kids, one of
whom cannot stop yelling, is tiring for her.
One day, she takes Brad to a new therapist in the
town. The man asks him about his parents’ divorce
and its effect on his life. Brad simply tells
him that he doesn’t remember much about the
incident and it doesn’t bother him at all.
The doctor refuses to believe it and claims
that Brad is in denial of the effect, which
might be causing the tics. He is yet again
misdiagnosed and told that the tics will
go away once he disciplines himself.
The only time Norman feels proud of being Brad’s
father is when Brad plays baseball. In the field,
everyone makes noises and moves, which makes
Brad feel like it is the only place he fits.
However, after every match, Norman brings his
sons home immediately to not embarrass himself
in front of the other fathers. Sometimes, the
constant moving and twitching make Norman lose
his temper. He often lashes out at Brad,
unaware that he cannot stop them.
Brad usually gets good grades and is excellent
at studying. However, trying to concentrate on
exams brings out the worst in him. The stress
makes his tics frequent and uncontrollable.
One day, his science teacher brings him to
the principal’s office for the hundredth time
for the same reason. The principal calls his
mother and agrees to give Bard the last chance
to stop the mischievous behavior. Ellen insists
that her son cannot help it but the principal,
in turn, calls her a bad parent for making
excuses for Brad’s bad behavior.
Having had enough of everyone blaming her
son, Ellen takes it upon herself to find
out the real cause of his symptoms. She does
extensive research on conditions that cause
people to yell and twitch. In the end,
she comes across Tourettes syndrome.
Brad finally has a way to prove that
he is not lying or being mischievous.
His therapist is also told about the discovery
and he praises Ellen for her great work. However,
the joy of finding out the problem vanishes when
Ellen realizes that the condition has no cure.
Her son will have to learn to live
with the noises, the twitches,
and the attention that comes with it.
Still, the saddest person to find out about
Brad’s condition is his father Norman. He is
guilt-ridden that he never believed his son,
but more than that, he is distressed that
the kid might not have a good future.
Although the cure is impossible, Ellen is
determined to teach her kid to learn to live
with Tourettes. One day, she takes him to a
support group for people with the same syndrome
as him. Meeting them was supposed to make Brad
feel better, but it makes him feel quite the
opposite. He feels like he is seeing himself from
other people’s eyes, and he doesn’t like the view.
Moreover, he finds out that everyone in
the room has given up on their lives. The
kids are homeschooled while the adults
get work-from-home-type jobs.
The experience is awful for Brad but it
is also the defining moment in his life.
Starting that day, he makes it his mission
to not be like the people from the support
group. He promises to be his own person and
never let the disability hold him back.
Even after he changes schools in seventh grade,
not much progress is seen in how people treat
him. The teachers always send him to the principal
and the classmates make fun of him. That is until
the principal finds out about Brad’s condition and
invites him to the stage during a school program.
Brad is asked to explain his syndrome to the
audience and explain what they can do to help.
After finding out that he actually
cannot help but make the noises,
people start being more sympathetic to him.
His life is never the same again. The principal
becomes that one teacher who helps him with
his biggest problem with ease and simplicity.
This makes Brad realize that he also wants
to be a teacher like him in the future.
Time flies by and Brad soon grows into a handsome
young man with a bachelor's diploma in education.
He moves to Atlanta and gets an apartment with
a roommate, hoping to land a teaching job.
The officer at the state education
board is impressed by his qualification.
However, she is skeptical if teaching would be a
suitable profession for someone with Tourettes.
Not just her, but most people Brad knows,
think the same about his choice of profession.
He understands their concerns to some level but he
knows in his heart that he was born to teach.
The very next day, he goes to his first
job interview. His tics visibly bother
the interviewer but he is not ashamed or
uncomfortable to explain his condition.
He also makes sure to assure the man that his
tics are an open topic for the students to discuss
and it won’t harm their studies in any way.
But the interviewer doesn’t seem convinced.
In the end, he is waitlisted.
The same thing happens at his next
interview and the one after that. He uses several
different methods, like talking about his tics for
the entire interview or not acknowledging it
at all. But none of them land him a job.
To take his mind off things, his roommate sets
him up on a blind date. He meets a girl at a bar
and is instantly attracted to her. The only
problem arises when people around them stare
at them because of Brad’s tics. By the end of
the night, his date is visibly uncomfortable to
be seen with him. It turns out that Brad has
never landed a second date with any woman.
He still hopes that one day, he will find
someone who can see him past his tics.
Brad’s father owns a construction business in
Atlanta and is ready to help him with money
until he gets a job. But Brad doesn’t want to
accept favors from Norman. The man still thinks
that Brad cannot survive as a teacher and
voices his opinion every chance he gets.
After twenty-five failed attempts at job
interviews, Brad has a mental breakdown in
his car. He feels hopeless and broken. But after
talking to his mother over the phone, he realizes
that the tics aren’t the reason for his failure,
he just hasn’t found the right school.
For the twenty-sixth interview, he goes
to an elementary school. The principal
and the vice-principal are already well informed
about Tourettes syndrome and do not make Brad feel
uncomfortable by treating him differently.
The interview goes on for two hours and is
the best one he has ever had. By now, Brad
has learned to not have high hopes, still,
he cannot help but wish to get the job.
To his surprise, the next day, he is called
to teach second graders. He is over the moon at
the news. Although he only has two days to prepare
for the class, he cannot care less about the
time and is excited to finally get to teach.
His fellow teachers welcome him and help him set
up the classroom. For the first time in his life,
Brad finds people who do not judge him for his
tics. At night, he calls his mother who pressures
him into dating a woman. Brad takes her advice
and meets a tinder date named Nancy the next day.
The two immediately hit it off but Bard feels
like he will be ignored after the first date
like he always has. Following the fun date,
they separate with a simple goodbye.
Later, Brad gets an email from her
praising his taste in music. He gets the
hint and invites Nancy to a second date.
The next day is his first day as a teacher.
Initially, the children laugh at his tics.
But then, he explains to them what Tourettes
syndrome is and what it does to people. Even
the second graders seem to be understanding
after finding out Brad cannot control the
noises. They ask him several questions,
all of which he answers happily. By the
end of the day, the kids love him.
But the same cannot be said for the parents.
When they come to pick their children up,
they seem to not like the new teacher.
Brad senses this but is confident that
they will like him after knowing him better.
Meanwhile, he continues dating Nancy and starts
falling in love for the first time. She genuinely
doesn’t seem to care about his tics and likes him
for his personality. In school, Brad bonds with
a cheerful little girl named Heather. She is the
smartest one in the class but it is her kindness
that catches his attention. When the other kids
make fun of Brad, she shuts them down. Some
parents request their kids to not be in Brad’s
class because of his disability. The school allows
it but Brad is asked to keep his head up because
the parents are the hardest part of the job.
One afternoon after school, Heather comments that
she is about to lose her hair. Her mother confirms
that the little girl has cancer and is undergoing
chemo. Still, the chances of her survival are
very low. The news saddens Brad to his core. The
mother also adds that Heather cannot wait to come
to school nowadays; he is the only person keeping
her happy during the last few months of her life.
The news only makes Brad feel bittersweet.
A few weeks later, Brad goes to take a test for
the master's degree but isn’t given a private room
as promised. He talks to the administration but
they refuse to help him. When he starts to panic,
Norman comes to his aid and threatens to sue
the administration. They eventually agree to
let him take the test in private. The incident
is a bonding moment for the father and son.
In the following scene, we see Nancy and Brad
go to his mother’s house for thanksgiving.
Seeing her socialize with her family, Brad cannot
help but get emotional. He pulls Nancy aside
and confesses his love for the first time.
Eventually, Heather stops coming to school. Her
classmates make letters and postcards wishing her
good health. But one day, they get the news they
had been dreading to hear. At Heather’s funeral,
Brad refrains himself from going inside, thinking
that he will disrupt the ceremony. But her mother
thanks him for being her daughter’s sunshine in
her darkest days and invites him in.
A few months later, Brad’s life is running
smoothly. He has a loving girlfriend, a good
relationship with his father, and a job that he
loves. Then, one day, he is called to a school
meeting and informed that he is being awarded
Sallie Mae’s first teacher of the year.
On the night of the event, Brad gives a heartfelt
speech that everyone loves. The movie ends with
a message that we should never let any obstacle
stop us from pursuing our dreams.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thanks for watching.